messieurs dames c'est avec une grande
émotion vue du canton de la première
vidéo dans ce studio à paris perd
bêtement en fait on n'a pas mis sa
caustique encore donc qui ça intéresse
beaucoup doivent justement moto2 les
coûts une personne groupe et le groupe
hayot aujourd'hui on fait un format un
peu chez nous le but est extrêmement
simple je rentre direct dans le concept
nous allons celle des moins vivre une
série de surprises ces surprises ont
pour but de faire monter notre bpm notre
battements par minute
évidemment dans la ville connaissait dès
que tu fais l'effort physique bâton bpm
monte vous dès que tu as de l'adrénaline
tu es surpris d'un truc qui angoisse est
tombé pm montrent aussi à chacun de ces
happenings de ses surprises
nous devons rester le plus calme
possible car celui de nous deux qui sera
monté le plus haut en bpm père la manche
lorraine va être la meneuse de cette
vidéo c'est elle qui a organisé tout ce
qui va nous arriver et elle va même y
réagir en direct dans une autre pièce
elle aura un retour vidéo en direct de
ce qui se passe ici et elle aura aussi
nos bpm sous les yeux mais l'a pour
l'instant vous n'avez pas encore vos
ceintures si je ne me trompe mais attend
des bombes dans des mbs quoi que ce soit
toi tu pars de la magnifique polar
modèle je sais pas l'entrée de gamme ou
pas j'en sais rien
ça marche très très bien j'ai pu la
tester mon m sur certains live donc
voilà on va mettre ça et puis ensuite le
reste je vais dans sa tour de contrôle
dans sa tour d'ivoire pendant que nous
nous serons au front à l'est amusant
[Musique]
tu sa place et l'endroit où tu sens le
cadre non mais là y'a quelqu'un de mort
par terre tu dois ont dit combien le vpm
vite vite vite une question de vie ou de
mort je pars en courant
c'est parti on leur met la télé et moi
j'ai menti
en fait c'est ça on est dans une pièce
et d'attendre c'est horrible même c'est
la pire chose c'est de se concentrer sur
son coeur c'est comme quand tu dois te
concentrer pour respirer c'est pas
normal c'est que ça un bon curry bas
alors qu'ils rien c'est que cette merde
il faudrait 130 sont au coeur il va au
betis pense la leçon est très bas et le
screamer leçon va être vraiment très aux
mecs mais attends c'est une dans la tête
de quelqu'un au fond à droite
maintenant on dirait que sous la couette
regard ya derrière il ya un truc sous la
couette horrible
deux chiens sur qui met pas son compte
elle mettre en pause du tournage hacker
qui comptez-vous c'est pas des choses
qui se font qu'est ce que tu fais là tu
as depuis combien de temps
ah c'est sûr que ma ba dessus je suis
abattu bravo en tout cas bravo pour la
cacher attends tu deviens un plat bon
les amis à votre avis qui est monté le
plus haut moi je crois que moi ça va un
peu plus tu monte à 130 je pense tous
les deux au début vous étiez à 130 quand
la vidéo a commencé oui mon jeu d'être
monte à 130 sommes aussi jeter trop
après vous êtes calmez vous est
redescendue et quand il ya l'escrimeur
tu es monté à 120 et toi t'es reste à
100 voilà désolé les cas bravo
bravo scène
vous savez pourquoi j'ai eu très très
peur et j'ai le sol quand j'étais petit
dans ma maison il y avait un escalier
pour aller au premier étage et une fois
mon d'imbéciles deux frères c'est un
musée et ses ténors avec ma supérieure
et un gars je crois mon bpm les montées
à 260 et donc lacombe show payet j à
bravo c'est bon j'ai impressionnable
dansault et d'être le méchant
machiavélique torture les jantes un mec
moi je veux mes pieds sur la table
maintenant c'est terminé
l'appelant et qui dépasse du cadam
savasem pour être sauvé on passe donc à
la deuxième vidéo qui a été tournée dans
les bureaux il faut voir quelque chose
arrivait dans l'escalier et ils vont
potentiellement en déduire que quelque
chose arrive dans le bureau mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait ce qui va se
passer
[Musique]
ils étaient vraiment là
oh mais c'est comme celle là on met
actuellement la haute ces marchés à la
porte qui mène au bureau mais c'est un
truc de famars et je te jure
oh non mais elle arrivée là c'est sûr
mec je me suis tu y vas être accrochées
des oblates faux
[Musique]
c'est normal non mais non j'ai tout ça
va aller pour de vrai t'aimes pas trop
fort mais il est en train de tuer sur un
trader
je subis le carton l'incroyable j'ai
encore perdu vas-y j'étais mort de l'âge
c'est là bas et je te vois dire genre
mais le cartoon là bas et j'ai fait
allez c'est fini mon ce que v où elle
est chic et machin les cobayes non les
gars très bien belle dalle bon à votre
avis c'est quoi je suis même pas morte
pendant ça je suis mort pendant les la
vidéo de la fin de la femme araignée
moi j'ai stressé dans le moment où ces
coupés et que j'attends je pense je
stresse à ce moment là et c'est là perdu
parce que c'est là que tu es monté plus
haut à west est monté à 120 au jeu après
ça tu monteras converse toi le maximum
c'était 117 ch quand adam excusez moi
mais y'a combien d'humains caché dans
cette pièce vous fassiez ça fait déjà 2
6 jouve ça il y en a un dont je suis sûr
c'est un anneau vous me prenez pour qui
sérieuse à l'arrière on est reparti pour
l'épreuve suivante
là ils ont augmenté la lumière ça veut
dire que ça va être quelqu'un qui va
venir présenter un truc horrible
[Musique]
c'était sur mech batteux super content
pour gueule non non non je vais mourir
mec ça va ce mignon mignon genre piqué
est très calme il fait lever regarder
comment il veut mais qu'il et kamla saab
sont restés calmes à la str4 je te la
prête ses excellents quand elle est plus
là ça va ça bosse à l'uqar remonte je
pense qu'il ya de l'adrénaline à
regarder son pote c'est quoi aller
mexicaine à son méga dangereuse en plus
elles sont beaucoup plus dangereuses que
les européennes
non j'étais jeune ouais bien sûr il
essayait starstreak s'est souvenu
poussins et celle ci a tué deux
mexicains c'est pour ça qu'on l'a ramené
en france voilà c'est une exploite alors
tout cas c'est très mignon je suis
agréablement surpris deux à quoi ça
ressemble donc si je vous jure les gars
dans la voix c'est vraiment dirait un
petit pokémon mignon c'est un truc de
ouf plus content lâche au plus pressé
juste heureux on peut la laisser trois
combats apprécient la police voilà entre
un petit singe c'est trop mignon
le gars ici en train de prendre la
confiance un truc de dingue mec je suis
étonné de kiffer ouais ouais moi aussi
je suis un pur d'admiration en tout cas
ils sont bien descendu dans le rythme
cardiaque
c'est pas plus mal comme ça on repart
d'une base neutre est les limouxins
ouais pourquoi c'est mignon mais les
gens n'ont pas du tout comprendre qu'on
les trouvait mini ouais je suis sûr que
personne n'a mis les pieds les jolies
content parce qu'on est en vidéo en
vidéo ça fait peur vous n'êtes vraiment
pas long ah ouais ouais vraiment
vraiment pas loin on a au maximum lucas
qui est monté à 116 bon ça va et ça
juste en dessous 112 donc genre vous
étiez vraiment pas loin moi j'ai
adoré mais c'était mais oui c'est quoi
cette phrase avec ce qu'on a dit
parce que ces cours des deux minutes
mais oui je suis désolé en tout cas
arrivent tous les arachnophobes là
décidément je n'arrête pas dans la vidéo
de vous désolé on va vous amener c'est
un jeu assez classique dans une petite
boîte nos petites mains le petit jeu
c'est parce que c'est un petit nouveau
si ça bouge
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la petite baie
rouge est juste soit mais oui tu as
juste
c'est toi qui va en premier que j'ai
fait la médiane en premier au charbon
très bon là c'est sûr j'ai déjà mort au
bpm ou la fhc bimoto là alors c'est
quelle texture jeu sans rien pas plus
loin
mais attends ça me fait stresser qu'il
ait pas de réaction je suis monté plus
au client bpm là je pense c'est parce
que ces jeux touchés comme sur du bout
des doigts
bon il est monté à 125 à temps calmes
parce que si c'est un animal sauvage
toxiques mais vous que je sois très
calmes
[Musique]
je suis dessus je dois chercher à jay o
mais c'est un petit certains ça c'est un
petit serpentins c'est un petit serpent
c'est un certain sûr c'est pas des des
carapaces de cafards ou un truc du genre
qu'arabes et caffari n'est pas loin vous
regarde
on va voir si le fait de regarder va
leur faire monter le chien j'ai trouvé
ça mais en fait c'est un mélange entre
usher pour le cafard c'est un hybride et
peut prendre
qu'est ce qu'il faut c'est bon aussi
mais ça me dégoûte un peu mois à temps
mais pardon mais j'ai d'enlever
impossible c'est le mien maintenant
d'accord j'y arrive
c'est cette qui a perdu quand tu savais
pas tu es monté à 125 étaient restés
assez calmes hockey et quand vous avez
vu ce que c'était
ouais toi tu étais assez calme et là tu
es monté à 120 donc quand même moins que
lui awa j'aurais failli perdre et on a
dégagé un devis noble ouais non mais oh
mais vous voyez galéré souffre et
j'étais sûr et certain que ça s'apprend
même genre vraiment donc on amène la
boîte suivante les amis hockey
[Musique]
n'ont plus qu'à commence la succion
lucquin j'aimerais pas être à ta place
en my god j'ai perdu j'ai le sol ça m'a
surpris de malades
tout allait bien et j'ai tout lu sur un
truc mais galure peut-être que l'udc
elle fait semblant attendez je crois
qu'il l'a brain va pas vers la droite va
surtout pas vers la droite l'udc a fait
sans le crier je le connais c'est sûr
pour faire en sorte que saab est plus
part des choses je ne touche c'est de la
mangue genre la cua cd qui me jean un tu
penses a dit que oui je sais pas j'ai un
boulot toi mon sens oui tu en sors un
sans paniquer qu'on voit ce que c'est
mais l'envoie pas valserres si j'avais
été sur le jeu lui est dans ma main on
joue avec un de mes ouailles ont coupé
chez vous les bat à mais si je perds sur
du kiwi je vais je vais râler alors les
petits résultant de la loi boîte et le
clou on avait testé j'ai testé ce matin
et j'ai vraiment eu peur je pensais
vraiment que c'était un truc non mais oh
c'est très dur la marche moi c'est
vraiment où j'ai pris un truc je fais ça
bouge toi tais toi t'es courageux
cette analyse trop bien il est trop fort
et la toute fraîche at il apprécié le
calme dans le carton je me rappelais
ouais ça c'est le cas tu as gagné
c'est fou tu es monté au maximum à 121
et 325
il y avait trois boîtes tu as gagné deux
boîtes ce qui fait que tu remporte cette
manche et qu'on peut passer à la manche
suivante sans voir la troisième boîte
sauvant la troisième on peut mettre un
petit jpeg de ce que c'était voilà je
peux pas croire qu'on finit cette vidéo
ça d'avoir vu un certain je ne peux pas
y croire
ils voulaient du serpent ils vont dire
voilà au mois le hyper beau mais c'est
mon pote imagine y graver mon oreille ça
peut s'agiter en serpent vraiment ah
ouais ça va vite un certain mais qu'un
ce post je fais ma musculaire ils sont
calmes ils sont très calmes le serpent
vient spécialement il est au calme
t'as vu ça ça me basile temps comme ça
il va naviguer je suis trouvé devant un
serpent je vous jure bas du pont de
fourche langue hindi ou et la chambre
des secrets mais oh bah oui mais bon mec
c'est fou mais je fais des bisous bob
jeu - c'est mignon mais en fait qu'un
était vraiment un serpentin mec tu as
fait le test harry potter au dessert je
crois que c'était mon tour je crois que
tu sortes règles à tout nul moi je
bouffe souffle tout cela pour vous
soutenir et vous il est tellement collés
à toi gros c'est un truc de ouf je suis
presque jaloux de la complicité entre
ces serpents et seb on est bon je pense
qu'il faut le récupérer
éloignant un peu ton visage crème grâce
à lui si non parce que pour la première
fois l'un de vous deux n'a pas dépassé
les 100 quelqu'un est resté vraiment
vraiment très calme
franchement j'en ai aucune idée eh ben
c'est lucas qui n'a pas dépassé les 100
ppm moi et mon idée au max 98 et toi tu
es monté à 112 alors qu'est ce qui va se
passer pour cette dernière manche
je sois calme vous allez chacun avoir un
petit un petit dossier dans ce petit
dossier il ya un thème et c'est un
exposé que vous allez présenter devant
40 personnes vous êtes trois minutes
pour la prendre
donc lui casser sur les chloroplastes et
toi c'est sur les mitochondries
et attention les gens posent des
questions ils sont calés en c'est
évidemment noté à la fin par les gens
pour votre prestation le regard droit
devant la faune non absolument pas
chérie tu paieras vous voilà j'ai déjà
perdu mon bep m il est à quatre mois au
sud elle donne vie sauve sur votre blog
bon je vous laisse à la réviser ok allez
vas-y vas-y on apprend vas-y merci
bonjour merci hein ok ok le cuir au
point spécifique des cellules végétales
[Musique]
mais quatre autres termes techniques en
fait ça se voit on arrive en 3ème année
d'un truc genre où tous les termes on
devrait les connaître le site aux mecs
c'est quoi c'est un médicament c'est un
truc dans une plante je comprends pas tu
as bah non c'est all donc c'est
compliqué elle vous prêts à volumes
choix mon dieu
maicon bonjour à tous bonjour alors on
est là vous parlez
un petit peu de chloroplastes
chloroplastes et de de mitochondries
donc dans notre binôme c'est moi qui
m'occupe de la particule europlace donc
voilà je vais commencer de spa lac leur
place c'est un organite présent dans les
cellules végétales des plantes
photosynthétiques uniquement les plantes
qui font de la photosynthèse mais alors
qu'est-ce que la photosynthèse c'est
vrai que c'est important de le rappeler
mais ça va très célèbre procédé grâce
auquel finalement une plante grasse à
l'énergie lumineuse va transformer du
dioxyde de carbone en sucre et le
stocker voilà c'était le petit point sur
le chloroplaste je suis peut-être allé
un peu un peu dit alors peut-être on va
vite
imagine tu as payé les places pour une
conférence je tombe sur target répondra
à toutes vos questions à la fin si vous
aussi vous en avez je vais laisser mon
ami vous parlez de la mitochondrie voilà
alors la mitochondrie si je peux me
permettre c'est que c'est relativement
deux choses très liés il faut savoir que
les mitochondries sont invisibles on
obligé de mettre du colorant du colorant
biologique pour pouvoir les observer au
microscope et quand on les observe
on se rend compte que c'est un schéma
plutôt simple qui paraît compliqué parce
qu'on utilise des termes c'est assez
technique d'un simple ovale avec deux
grosses membrane avait exemple avec au
museu intéressant c'est que vous dites
oui avec au milieu pardon genoux comme
n'en avait cure ce qu'on appelle
l'espace un termite mitochondrial sur le
côté des deux membranes ce qu'on appelle
les crêtes
ouais et celle là dedans on retrouve
l'adn excellent excellent et marc voilà
c'est pour souligner un peu les
différences caire entre entre ces deux
mêmes entre se désole mans ces deux
éléments qui nous servent au quotidien
du coup voilà est-ce que vous avez des
questions alors là cellules grises voilà
c'est les clodos disque qui composent
les disques et membranes ils ont
totalement mixer voilà chloroplastes et
le et sa forme de disque pour que ça
donne les clés roddick de manière est
sombre
voilà merci merci on vous a épargné que
les trucs un petit peu chiant parce que
bon c'est un sujet assez compliqué nous
on voulait amener vraiment ce côté
simplifier je veux pas parler par
exemple de la matrice du tout compris à
lui par ex
bon je pense qu'on a on a donné à cette
carte en main dans un étudiant je vais
me rendre à oman à notre manager votre
manager vous pourrez procéder au
règlement de la conférence on va
profiter à la dotation parce que dans un
pilote suisse de notation c'est à dire
que la note si vous m ça va dire le
vainqueur je reviens nous vendre wally
nous revoilà déjà petits débris sur
cette confiance qu'en avez vous pensé
moi ça m'a rappelé les pires situations
où c'est celle où on te demande des
trucs août et censées avoir la réponse
et tu ne les as pas et tu fais genre tu
les as c'est donc avant cette 6e manche
qui vient de se passer
on en est à la 5ème avec trois du côté
lucas et deux du côté de sède ça pouvait
se jouer maintenant et ça a été le cas
parce que du coup durant la conférence
alors c'était surtout il annonce de la
conférence qu'a fait la diff et le temps
de préparation c'est là on avait des bpm
ouais ok on a eu un bon record de lucas
qui est monté à 131 j'aime tellement pas
s'arrête alors c'était c'est super calme
pendant la conférence
même pendant les révisions le maximum
que tu as fait c'est 115 d'être à
égalité
eh ben c'est ça on était à 3 3 mais la
note finale à d'affiner le gagnant c'est
ça donc la note de l'exposé la note de
l'exposé que les gens vous ont donnés a
pas du tout été 2 mais vous avez essayé
franchement vous en êtes vraiment bien
tu vois plus par le tout cela me dérange
de la même quand tu te parler mais quand
est ce qu'on va arrêter il connaît tout
nouvel déjà franchement vous avez bien
le mondial est bien tiré chaque de coups
de mecs parce que vraiment on a été
monstrueux
je suis sûr que si j'avais fait monter
peu avec toi j'aurais eu une bien
meilleure note que onze n'ont plus qu'à
tuer la note de 12 sur 20 à manger mais
pour ce que tu as fait et septua la note
de 12,8 sur un jeu plus oui quelqu'un
adoré faire exploser parce que quelqu'un
1018 parmi des notes habache l'adorent
et tu lui dis je vais écrire un discours
où il voit que l'uimm et ben voila serré
c'est bon ou st cyr et cela veut dire
que c'est vraiment fidèle away vraiment
s'est-elle travaux je fais toutes les
bannières demain en tout cas c'était
vraiment marrant comme concept j'ai
moins aimé faire ça c'était vraiment
sympa bravo à vous bravo 7 pour sa
victoire sur un plot dimanche
en tout cas c'est super merci à vous
d'avoir regardé la vidéo on laissait
faire de plus de concepts comme ça cette
année là c'est très rigolo en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à suivre la chaîne de
youtube de soc je le rappelle par simple
politesse coup férir il raconte de
belles histoires à mes attendant une
prochaine vidéo j'ai perdu j'ai le
sommes
[Musique]